okay so for those listening on this live
stream we are about to embark on a
software architecture review for a piece
of functionality which will be in an
experimental form in the next version of
Wolfram language I really haven't seen
any of this particular design yet and
what we're talking about is the
connection between Wolfram language and
MongoDB something that we have been
building internally for use with our
machine learning training frameworks but
we'll be making it it also available to
users okay so I think Sebastian maybe
you should share here and give us a demo
shop so share screen okay do you see my
screen I do okay cool so to run this
there's instructions here for hundreds
of this on your local machine once
you've installed MongoDB on you wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute so there is a default install
of MongoDB and it uses a certain port
yes default port okay and that is the
default port and from the [ __ ]
installation exactly so MongoDB ways use
this port if you install it locally but
he follows there okay okay fine
okay and what happens if you want to use
a different port I mean if your MongoDB
installation is different yeah is there
he I mean we have some kind of IP
address wrapper which contains port
numbers don't we that's a good question
you look at if you look at IP address
and just go into the you know our
documentation um okay so that's an
address okay I'll look up look up look
up look in the seal so is there see also
first look up sucker connects your elf
intelligence Oh socket connect look at
socket connect okay so that is a host
and a port number see there yes you can
give it some support number
is a symbol that's an object okay I see
you okay cool that's great so let me
just actually rather than doing that
from the documentation I'm just gonna
open it from this place so that we don't
destroy the states okay all right so
I'll just make a note here as well I'll
have this okay but yeah so you can you
can set the port over see at the moment
there's a default argument for yeah the
two arguments are host and imports okay
which should be packaged differently
because that that's the way they're
packaged in the socket objects yes and
that thing should also accept a socket
object exactly yeah so this is a good
very good point okay
notes okay cool so basically on your
local machine if you've installed
MongoDB you can just run on gods okay
back up back up to what we have what
happened there so you said open [ __ ]
connection that is very different from
the structure of other kinds of database
connections right what what is the
analogous thing for in the new database
framework what's the analogous thing it
would be something like database Connect
would it not will be the name of the
function that's a good question I copy
this open sequel connection I think yeah
but that's from the old database link
yes being not from the new thing I think
it's database Connect does anybody here
know nope okay aunt :
and Ricardo Ricardo and the mother yeah
I mean are you not sure that this is
like the same level as disconnect I
think I know I know that like we're kind
of busy link is going to be deprecated
somehow I'm just I'm just looking at the
naming conventions here you know given
that this is if look the first question
is right now this is purely a [ __ ] link
eventually it will be a general link to
some kind of key value store presumably
I'm not Shawn
I'm not sure about us yeah sure either I
mean it might be the case that this this
gets completely subsumed by what Ricardo
lay on it and I are doing and and it's
like this is what's running under the
hood in that case this would just be one
of the things that it's an option you
know if you do a database connect and
the target database is MongoDB then this
is what would happen exactly and and if
we're going to do that then clean
database connect now might be pronoun no
I'm not suggesting suggesting I'm simply
suggesting that can go connect to
something
yeah MongoDB connect I mean I would
think that was probably the
corresponding what you know that's a
minor suggestion I think that's probably
what we should do can think that's
enough anyway what we are doing and we
are managing the connections and so
basically you can query it at the moment
without the overhead connection but
basically is this very connection but
the back you are specifying the
connection does it mean Katrine doing
the actual connection operation then you
just pass these arguments later to wear
something and the case as a function
database Connect that returns a lazy
database connection or is it does it
work differently this is amazing wait
wait wait wait I'm trying to understand
from from Ricardo there these
connections and basically open open and
close and this is returning the open-air
connection at the moment no no I
understand that that's a query but I'm
saying you've got a database sitting out
there in the world you want to create a
quote potentially lazy but you want to
create a connection to that database how
do you do that
well you have a database connection
object and the fact that you actually
have this object how do you get the
database connection object you write it
or because basically in the end is yeah
is a link like Sebastian is doing long
or a civilization with engine so you are
explicitly writing that there is no
creator function that I mean so I don't
understand here in the case of this
MongoDB Connect a MongoDB Connect or
whatever it's called you're saying that
on a local machine
this is connecting to the single [ __ ]
instance with that port number on the
local machine is that correct that's
correct and that is that the typical way
that [ __ ] is run to have a single
instance on the local machine it's like
a multi be the two sort of major ways of
running it so one is on your local
machine in order to like stream very
quickly out of core data so for net
train we'll use it for that sort of way
and the other way is that you use it as
if you have a cluster of machines and
then you can connect the cluster back to
the primary of the cluster or something
but either way you're saying so what
you're saying is that the okay this
MongoDB Connect contains some kind of
socket specification and you're giving
their various various forms of socket
specification which you should really
get from the way that socket connect
works yeah for these ones yes right but
okay but that's fine but so then and but
the most common way is actually with
with a string so it's with so if you
have a cluster MongoDB gives you like a
string that represents the entire
connection all the SSL options and
whatnot this is very short but like a
complicated cluster has a very long
string well that's probably URI so
that's the most common way of connecting
so it takes this URI object you know
[ __ ] client and a [ __ ] URI is one
essentially lazy and the other not a URI
is just a specification for like it
represents yeah all the information
needed to connect I understand why I'm
asking that one seems like it's like a
lazy connection which might or might not
have actually been made whereas the
[ __ ] client thing up there is a
connection that has actually been made
is that correct or is that not correct
that's not correct this is just it
represents this your I and you use the
Uriah to connect with the connection and
it validates whether your eyes corrects
whether longer didn't you Riley what's
the difference I don't know why you need
that why don't you just give if that's a
unique mapping from [ __ ] URI
Strang why don't you just give that
string in the MongoDB connect function
show him you can do that as well you can
use the stroke why do we care about that
[ __ ] URI ever why do we ever need to
see the [ __ ] URI ah don't you see it's
okay
there's no function okay yeah yeah it
does validate them you're right but I
guess you can always just try and
connect with it and this object is
called database connection and if you
feed to this guy and URL it evaluates
with an additional statement so
basically even to the civilization you
have fixed that line just for my sake
prefix that line with the word note
Sebastian so you don't forget to remove
it from okay okay so that's it sounds
like what Ricardo has done for the
database stuff is is the same pattern
you should probably follow here okay all
right let's keep going here and then
what gets returned where you see [ __ ]
client you know that should surely be a
MongoDB
connection object okay so this is
actually the first piece where the
philosophy of what we're doing can come
in so let's do sort of philosophies for
this packet like this so we want to have
for certainly for multiple like the most
popular databases it makes sense to have
very close to the design of the other
drivers and other languages and these
are often then used you know for the
higher-level framework that Ricardo in
the MOU building so Postgres will
probably have something similar and
there's sometimes you want to have the
actual features of Postgres you know
exposes but sometimes you just you know
you want to just have a high level
overview interface to it which is what
they're building
so one yeah so the design philosophy
they've taken for this whole package is
that I follow all the other MongoDB
clients and Python and Java etc
so that this virtual surprise and use
the same names I use the same function
that's the mistake I just don't think
it's I mean well let's see what these
look like so just quickly before word
yeah so I've started the stuff on my
computer
yep so I can now connect and yeah
there's all these equipment ways of
connecting and we can actually do a
query which is okay so I guess I'm going
to be the way that it works is that
there's two different levels of
hierarchy there are databases which are
sort of big base collections of things
and then their collections so yeah
actually this is a good thing to maybe
mention quickly so am I going to be this
database I'm sorry
a database is a collection and there's a
document oh yeah
so doc document is just an association
in Mathematica a collection as the data
sets or a list of s actually I should've
using sorry it was parlons collection
would be table so you said in SQL
ponents section is a table does document
is a water that your document is a role
in a collection of table yeah so this is
row yeah in this case obviously it's
arbitrary nested document associations
which is the nice property that we know
it can be arbitrarily mustard which is
not exactly yes and our machine learning
data is exactly this form it's like very
nested data that doesn't hurt Lisa but
really data sets happily support
arbitrarily nested things yes exactly so
jealous that's exactly so there's an
exact one-to-one mapping almost between
data sets and documents in Hmong so what
is a database a database is a collection
of collections or what exactly is just a
collection of collections into the
I guess you can yeah I mean it's named
so database one goes to a collection yes
it's an association of elections okay
and why exactly is it not just the data
set of data sets I mean you're saying it
happens to be an association of data
sets yeah okay fine exactly okay all
right okay so that's the hierarchy yeah
okay so you can see the database names
and then you can connect to database and
you can connect with two different ways
either but get or just with this
argument syntax on the objects and then
you get a database objects gives you the
name and the idea of the database and
then you can do things like at the
collection which is just the same sort
of syntax or why the way is it right to
call it [ __ ] collection as opposed to
MongoDB collection okay I mean this is
something we can decide I don't know you
told me what do you think it's more
sensible I think [ __ ] is better MongoDB
everything in front of its I don't know
okay fine all right that's a pretty
uncommon name [ __ ] so I don't think
I'll be a namespace clash easily well I
mean this is not gonna be in system
context anyway right yeah exactly yeah
it's just a package context okay hold on
hold on I don't understand okay so the
things that are coming back here are
essentially pointers to [ __ ]
collections and things like this right
now normally would call things like that
[ __ ] collection object and so on yes
[Music]
and if I look at what's going back there
I see that is is what you were in my
opinion what you should do here when you
say ID two and things like that
instead of saying name whorfin test you
should say collection Cola more from
test database column whatever because
that way you'll have a clean thing which
will show you you know document
collection database when you've drilled
all the way down
okay I thought the name was quite
self-evident if it's a collection
objects yes but but it will be clearer
given you've also got database there it
just seems like a natural way to do it
if you call if instead of that you call
I'm just a suggestion I'm not sure
it's--yeah call the name collection
because then you'll get a nice thing
where when you get down to a [ __ ]
document it'll say you know and yeah
it'll have it all yeah okay fine okay so
hold on okay so keep going let's just
let's just see some more stuff okay
so among the documents yeah it's an
association there's a set of types that
obviously natively supports and there's
a Soviet yeah okay what is to be sawn
where's that not export string this on
is the binary JSON yes exactly so Sabina
it's an import export format of ours yes
it's not yes annex and put export
formats well it should it could yeah so
it could be well it should be I thought
we did have a binary we do yeah we have
you JSON or something Oh your input
that's right
so this is an alternative format so we
should actually install it then as it
sounds like a fine thing to do is it
obvious so you've built an import/export
framework for beasts on yes exactly and
it produces either binary arrays or or
byte array sorry from a yeah from a JSON
or it produces a string representation
or whatever else this is exactly like
the you JSON version okay well so can we
please make sure sushma can you make
sure that that is is actually set up as
an import/export thing maybe durian
should do it since he knows how to do it
from having done UB JSON
yeah I assume you don't know how to do
that quickly so a true statement
the IMP I have done some importers and
exporters but it will be faster for own
Murray
Oh Howard dates reported like because in
Jason they are increase reported like
you have you have some deviation okay
that's that's a great question
so just so people know about this so two
bees on there's a set of types that bees
on supports so peas on is like an
extended JSON so it supports everything
that JSON supports but it also supports
some extra types so yes it has a very
very of type annotating things like
dates and these are the types of sports
show me okay so you're saying given a
welcome language expression that
contains a date there is a B song
representation of that shortened correct
yes what is all this stuff
wait a minute but this is okay so all
databases have types that they support
yeah and these are the types that's
these on supports and that [ __ ]
supports fine by the way I don't use
capital letters on the right hand side
oh yes you're right see right no that's
not the most serious problem here okay
so you know so let's go back for a
second because in the in our usual
framework I mean okay maybe there's some
special function in this mangu
are we calling it what was what was the
name of the context here is it [ __ ] or
MongoDB its Munger link it's the context
all right fine but in the [ __ ] link
context you can have all kinds of weird
stuff but for anything serious that's
actually going to be you know I mean we
should clearly have a be song importer
now what you're saying is you've also
got beasts on to JSON converters which
we would naturally do you know we don't
naturally have a converter we have
something that goes you know import it I
mean I guess you can import it to a byte
array or something and then yeah it's a
little funky right because you can say
you can import the B song and then
export it again as JSON and again sense
not it not not and I was reading this
there are a lot of things that measles
reports that Jason doesn't well but
Sebastian has Abby's on to JSON
converter which is obviously lossy well
no it's not
so it actually so what it does is yeah
let me show this so basically if the
type is not a JSON then it's called this
strict conversion to JSON and then it
will say this you can't convert all this
I could loose conversion and then it
annotates the types is this is a number
instant number double okay fine
so that's a that's a fascinating form of
training we don't currently have that
means that we need yet another the it's
some let's see we that somebody is
asking by the way on the live stream by
lazy database connection we mean that it
will automatically reconnect when
attempting to use the thing if the
connection is dropped I believe the
answer to that is yes right Carlo and
Ricardo if if when we have for the
database framework the lazy connection
if the server
drops the connection right we will
automatically reconnect is that not
correct I think that connection is kind
of a misnomer in this case it's more
like it's it's I mean whenever you're
asking for data that interconnects and
whatever it stopped asking for then it
drops so it will automatically reconnect
if the server for some reason decided to
drop the connection when you ask for
data again this will reconnect yes sir
good there is another thing related to
connections I want to ask Sebastian
because we've even supports decimals we
don't really have anything equivalent to
decimals in in Wolfram language right
now sometimes richness but it's what do
you mean by decimals you mean binary
coded decimal is binary coded decimal
still with us
no not binary
it's it's so decimal it's like a float
but instead of being binary it's never
died that was in you know right that
that's binary coded decimal was for
exactly that purpose right because
ultimately it's stored in binary right
yes but you have a guaranteed that I
mean it's useful it does rounding
differently from from binary from double
and float and it's it's very important
for life banking application was
invented you know using mainframes in
the early 1960s that's fascinating that
particular issue is not I mean if we're
going to talk about that issue we should
talk to the numerix group about that
issue and I guess mark Stefani was
probably the person to talk to I mean if
we really want to have something like
that I had some tauten email about it
some time ago and I had some responses
yeah that's not that's an interesting
thing to discuss is you know some kind
of mechanism for you know it's oh gosh I
can't believe like the rules for
position I mean it's like calculators
you use BCD and we're and that's why
when you do like the shift map with 2x
part one onyx Raizel do totally crazy
things whereas on a computer it will
typically not do crazy things by the way
we're hearing somebody is it needs to
adjust their microphone um okay so let's
go back here let me just understand this
beast on JSON etcetera
okay can we can we just put one thing is
beasts on import and export now what
you're saying is there is another form
of JSON which is a type some kind of
typed JSON thing where types that it
doesn't understand it tags in some
special way is that correct
well it just has boobies on because it
has extra types adjacent have yeah this
is what that's saying is but that is a
form of JSON that presumably is can
losslessly go back to beasts on in this
case exactly rights so what that the
issue there is that we have these
various forms of JSON in our
import-export framework and this is yet
another one well this is just pure JSON
think it's perfectly valid just as pure
JSON but the fact is it has to know in
this case the the natural way that we
would go from you know what we have is
beasts on to expression we don't have a
beasts on direct to JSON in our standard
import-export framework it's not you
know we don't have an import exactly I
see were saying jpg to PNG or something
we're going through you know an image
because there hasn't really come up as
an important thing to be able to do so
we need to think about that I mean in um
you know it is possible that there is
enough of a proliferation of JSON
formats that just like we have various
string to string conversions that we
should have various JSON to JSON
conversions you know for example in the
case of strings we have all sorts things
with character encoding but we
essentially have string to string
conversions that that work with
different character encodings I can
imagine you know if we're really if this
proliferation of types of JSON is not
slowing down and you know I'm now
hearing but another one that I've never
heard of before if that's really the
case then we should consider doing
something like character encodings with
strings with Jason's did that make sense
yeah that make sense okay so who I mean
the I guess tally was a big enthusiast
of these various you know he was the one
who introduced whatever it's called raw
JSON and so on so I guess we need to
have a discussion that includes tally
and I'm not exactly sure who has been
dealing with maintaining the JSON
importers and exporters was Dorian and
the out Dorian was involved I wrote the
main historian here Dorian was supposed
to be here I am here can you hear me yes
so do you have any comments on these
JSON things
no I think that's yet another schema for
to express new data on JSON format I
agree but my question is my question now
and I see your point and yeah it makes
sense maybe to have a to Jason from
Jason function what good is that gonna
do us that the whole problem with that
is no the problem is JSON to JSON
conversion is what we can't do we can do
an expression what's that why would you
convert JSON to JSON well that's what
you're doing here you're converting
piece onto JSON yeah well that's
different
that's piece onto JSON well okay it's
close enough though it's a JSON like
format okay
so I guess that means the same thing
with new JSON and all that like you
might want to import you JSON to or from
language or you might want to convert to
JSON directly well you might I don't
know whether you do but but okay the
point that I'm making is let us figure
out and maybe Dorian and you can figure
this out whether it makes sense to try
to have essentially a you know JSON
manipulation functional family of fun
it's probably going to be a JSON convert
function or something like this um that
will basically be something of the form
I would I would imagine what it would be
if you just write this down something
like now let's see I mean we could
imagine okay listen we could imagine
something that's something like um what
would the name be well let's just try
saying convert although that wouldn't be
the name because that's way too general
a name and then let's say an expression
there or typically this spring and then
it'll be something like you know quotes
format one arrow quotes format too
I see I mean you could you could say
format convert but I am NOT very than
there but then most of those conversions
would be supported by basically just you
know import the thing if we say I mean
that that might be a useful function to
have you know gift to TIFF or something
exactly yeah I think it's useful thing
to have but but but now I mean the real
case that's gonna be useful is where the
output where it's filed the file they'll
be the most common case where that
expression is really a file and where
the output is also a file yeah exactly
often I mean but that will be
represented I don't really know okay so
listen that this this this thing then
should be discussed in the import-export
meeting which by the way we haven't had
for a while we should be having one of
those um and I mean you know we haven't
needed this because we can always go
through the intermediary of having
something to be an expression but if it
makes sense to do so in other words
mostly this conversion you know it's
like language translation mostly you
know if you're if you're translating
from you know catch her to Swahili or
something you know it's very unlikely
that you're gonna have a direct
translation you're most likely gonna go
through English or something right off
and so similarly in um yeah right so so
fine so in this case we would support a
few direct translations and mostly will
be going through an expression
intermediary alright let's let's go back
to to what you were talking about before
okay so okay that's in okay so the
association ultimately the association
that you get for the document is okay so
the limit Carlo had raised a thing about
date objects but are you satisfied with
the answer to that about that caller
yeah I once regret the Wikipedia page
it's actually represent it as
milliseconds from so it's well tag it's
sorry you don't get confusion with the
number okay fine okay so so that is a
canonical form up so that is a form of
JSON used by MongoDB as that right yeah
exactly and it's mono by default use
be son as its internal representation is
that how it works that's correct okay
but for our purposes it will be as if
you have the let's see it's it's as if
you um you know what you see inside
Wolfram language is basically a an
expression you know an association with
expressions in it
the fact is I think underneath there's
some beasts on mattresses the relevant
okay only reason that I document this
here is that you can see the types was
it it's important to know what types are
supported natively okay but that that's
that's merely documentation alright it's
me yeah exactly I mean we are we doing
anything where when you try and load
something in and it doesn't have the
right type you know and it has are you
declaring the types when you load it or
not so well no so I mean I can see what
the types are and if it doesn't if the
type is not in B's on then it will fail
to converse but you can also put a rule
potentially saying that if the type is
not known you can converse to a string
for example and it all okay when you
load the thing up when you originally
create the MongoDB database okay are you
giving a tighter schema which involves
types no so there's there's no schemas
involved at all so it's just a it has a
certain set of types at always briefer
also any given to people exactly but so
any given field could be a date it could
be a number it could be this it could be
that or not okay so by default yes but
you can opt into checking so you can
have schema validation fine that's a
different thing and we've also got I
mean clearly we have a schema validation
scheme so to speak for the database
integration system to is almost akin
right okay let's keep going coming can
we keep going here sure okay so this is
set you can have an association and
obviously it can be arbitrary nested so
hold on is you can see how you access
that from oh could you scroll up a bit
sure I
further up and that's right okay so I
want to just go I've got a handle - I've
got one of those your eyes strings that
is a handle to a MongoDB database yes
and then what do I do
ultimately I am extracting I don't
understand why you're doing among go get
collection all this kind of stuff I
don't understand why it isn't just an
extraction that looks like insofar as I
mean why isn't the whole [ __ ] database
as if it was a data set okay so
basically what you're saying is so what
you can already do is like you can say
you know you've got a client's and then
you can say you know database and then
collection name - could you write that
with a lowercase D to not confuse me
sorry database right so that's the name
of the database the name of the
collection and then the name of and then
you can go into the Association inside
the collection right no you can go in
the collection is then a data set it's
at any sense right so then you can keep
going presumably and an access link well
okay so that's it yeah so we'll get to
that know how to access things there's a
few tricky nurses but yes you could
convert it straight for database if you
wanted to yes of course
you've got average of dallisa directly
but you often don't want to do that
because it's using this often when
you've got massive data sets right I
understand so well nothing so I mean one
of the things we that would be a great
goal here is to use MongoDB as backing
store effectively for a dataset yes
that's a that's one use of this sort of
thing right but but how what is the most
seamless way to do that so in other
words let's say you've got I mean what
will be really nice is to be able to put
inside a data set a essentially a
MongoDB connection object and to have
that mean you know this data set has a
virtual backing right a usual data set I
mean this is the original idea of data
set is to have multiple kinds of backing
stores
yes right and so in this case we seem to
be quite close with this to being also
just say dataset of a MongoDB connection
and have that be a lazily accessed thing
that goes through the MongoDB system is
that right or am I'm confusing something
you're pretty right yes so the main
thing is so the way in so the main work
that's required is to translate things
like selects and all that sort of thing
to [ __ ] queries I almost done the same
thing that's required in the case of the
database integration project exactly so
can I ask a question of the the okay so
the model that we have in the database
project is that things are entity stores
right guys yes yes and and the
difference here so in a sense the
database integration project the
relational database integration project
is providing a backing store for data
for entity stores is that a correct
statement yeah that is correct now in
principle one could also could one not
in in certainly well maybe this is crazy
but is it the case that certain
databases are simple and degenerate
enough like a single table for example
that that they could actually just be
represented as data sets if there are no
foreign keys and it's just a table its
it is a data set isn't it is that silent
thinking or is that I think yes but
color them might know better Carlo I
guess you can think about data sets well
but yeah I mean in general everything
that that can on foreign key that is
self-contained can be things does that
so yes if you don't have foreign keys
you might think you might basically
represent that as well with the data set
also data set here in MongoDB is uh is a
better fit because is uh is completely
you know there is no schema so basically
you can totally terror so I mean if we
are building a backing store from
scratch so to speak
for a data set then MongoDB is the
choice but the other question is if as a
you know as a piece of you know some
random data science project you are
handed some random legacy database and
told to do things with it my question is
can you view that database absent
foreign keys as a you know a table in
that database as a data set that's my
question in our design for database
integration is there a convenient way to
have essentially a virtualized data set
I mean what we're doing for entity value
basically that is returning that we're
gonna have we don't have it now but
basically when you do entity value you
can just say you can just have like a
you know from from an entity you just
construct the data set and this can be
like entity property Association or
something well we do have that in the
built-in entities if you say entity
value of you know tungsten for example
comma data set you will get a try it try
it control equals you know what are you
doing just taken what to control as I
ooh yeah holy forth I was not anything
there yep
tungsten tungsten heard anta so ash is
thinking oh gosh that bug again okay
wrap that whole thing in entity value
tungsten entity value of tungsten comma
dataset it's what you're going to do
which is across quote comma quotes data
set Teddy sighs okay and return okay so
there we go so this is actually doing
exactly what we just described what what
recorded isn't so that's it so that's a
fine thing so that can be for certain
databases that will be okay there you go
yeah magnificent okay okay so fine so so
what this is saying but but nevertheless
what we don't have there is something
where you can say data set and then give
it a database connection object exactly
we don't have that yet right but but we
can have that you know the first case
where it makes sense to have this for
the non MongoDB thing and potentially it
makes sense to have that for regular
databases with the caveat well what you
guys are saying is that you have to link
it to an entity is that what you're
saying rather than to a database
connection Ricardo sorry okay so what
I'm saying is under what circumstances
does a database yeah it doesn't make
sense because it's a table in a database
that corresponds to if I'm not mistaken
that corresponds to the data set so did
you agree well is that we have right now
is that our database table is a single
entity yes
it's a single entity mm-hm
okay like in an entity store is the
whole database and store in an entity
store gonna have more than one entity
okay much like the tungsten thing we
just saw which is the data which is
earth right then it makes sense to the
table level to just have a data set of
course it will be a fly
that was it because that's the
underlying data structure that you have
but yes you can do that okay it's
actually nice because basically you know
you're you're you use the NC language
basic Express query in there are
basically presented another face but
then when you want to continue in memory
because I don't know you have like a
small data set right now you can
actually continue with a data set for
example you know I understand that's why
okay but in your model you are basically
putting it in memory when you when you
do this query you're putting it in
memory you're extracting the data set
into memory when you're doing that is it
right now yes of course nothing is
blocking us from having you know so what
we next want is a parallelism between
what we're doing with MongoDB but it
seems like monk because we want this
possibility of a virtualized legacy
database sitting out there that is
accessed as a data set but let's go back
to looking at the MongoDB case okay so
can you keep going down okay so now so
now we have certain operations like
[ __ ] I see [ __ ] collection insert oh
my gosh and you can see that this form
here it basically it corresponds to the
crud Apio of MongoDB so this function
for all the different versions returns
this exact set of things okay so hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on I mean I
don't think that's the right thing to
return I think you should return a
success object if that's what you are
really doing inserted IDs so using like
just make a success object that has
object that has because it will format
nicely as a success object if that's
what if that's I mean in other words we
don't usually have metadata like the
insert function for lists just returns
the list right that has been inserted
into so the things that this would
naturally return you know more naturally
this would return the you know some
pointer to the collection
some pointer to the newly mutated
collection right you see what I'm saying
but the alternative here given that you
seem to want to return meta information
is to return a success object okay let's
let's come back to this okay so this is
going into a territory that has not been
gone in the database intubation project
because that doesn't have right
capability so we should if it's Carlo
here call up paying attention okay sorry
okay okay no problem okay so look the
the you know we started to talk about
insertion to MongoDB databases and for
this we need to be thinking a little bit
how we're going to imagine doing
insertion in the database integration
project okay let's keep going
Sebastian can you keep going with this
Shawn okay so you can get so basically
with keys you can either give it a
unique key or you can let it generate a
unique key for you so this is like an
automatically generated key that has
information about when it was generated
and all that sort of thing so you can
actually how do I as I can mm-hmm how do
I insert how do i specify what key I
want used Shawn so basically a MongoDB
uses a special convention that says
that's anything the base key called ID
this will be the you can that'll be the
key yeah I mean it's a decent way to be
so yeah but it's also rather yucky and
not necessarily and consumer is
something we should wrap in a different
way and depending on whether what we're
trying to do is just look it seems to me
there are two objectives in this project
now one of them is to support to just
have a low-level interface to MongoDB
well okay so the real question is do we
imagine that the use cases a MongoDB
database already exists and we are
connecting to it and tweaking it in case
one or case two what we got was a giant
table all of a bunch of you know of 10
million images or something and we want
to store them and we turn them into a
MongoDB database do you understand the
quest
because I'm the database integration
project what we are imagining is that
what we are primarily dealing with is
pre-existing databases that have been
created you know in the sort of general
course of human affairs so to speak I
see so let me ask this question from the
point of in terms of machine learning
data sets for example are there ones
that are currently being flat you know
being sent around as MongoDB databases
or is it that they're mostly just you
know file systems less than the file
systems okay that is yeah yeah how is
the metadata typically represented as
JSON there's like massive JSON files but
where is that metadata is did one
central piece of metadata is it within
the file system somehow no it separates
so they there does have a massive JSON
or a collection of Jason's okay so
natural okay so then one of the
operations that we're gonna need is take
the file system and the collection of
JSON metadata and construct from it a
MongoDB database is that correct yes
I guess that's yeah we wrote an internal
version of this thing that does exactly
that okay and is there a standard for
the format of the JSON metadata okay
it's messy so example of this I mean one
classic database or data set that we've
got is a Miss cocoa that has things like
bounding boxes it has segmentation masks
it has descriptions of the images it has
tons and tons of metadata and you know
things like the bounding boxes I've seen
like four different conventions that
people use for I represent them so you
know you have to convert them carefully
and even though yeah things like the
segmentation masks so data scraping
project exactly we're not okay
automating this is very hard but from
the point of view of the workflow that
we expect our users to go through we
expect that what's gonna happen is they
receive a giant blob of of you know you
know whatever it is tar ball or
something of fire
and metadata JSON information and so on
and then they open that up and then they
are going to use Wolfram language code
to create a thing which happens to be a
MongoDB database but as far as they're
concerned the most important thing is
that they're just using Wolfram language
code to go from the original thing that
they were sent to this thing that is
conveniently storing their data is that
correct sure I guess in the long run yes
that would be what are you doing right
now are using some lower-level tool to
go from the tarball to the to the
initial condition the [ __ ] DB DD DB
exactly I mean it's just a Wolfram
language script that converts it into
the format that we needed and then it
converts it that's what I'm saying is
that that what we the thing you haven't
shown me here but maybe you are showing
me now is you know given a giant file
system okay I would like to just be able
to say in one fell swoop with something
like file system scan you know something
like file system map but it wouldn't be
file system map it will be more like you
know file system to database or
something just seek that whole file
system and stick thing in the database
sure do we say we do in a yeah we've got
a special package in machine learning
for uploading our data sense so we have
yeah you have a massive file system you
have lots of metadata and you can choose
at the moment we send all the files
stuff to s3 but you could also put it
into MongoDB if you wanted to but for us
we've there's various reasons why it's
better to put on history okay but I mean
the what you're saying then is that the
MongoDB stuff is just storing the
metadata there and the point is the
actual file pointers are pointing off to
s3 exactly that's how we're internally
storing it okay there's some bleeding
yeah so things like segmentation masks
they also store them there could be a
file or there could be in the database
it's a bits I anything goes I understand
but okay so there is some okay but I
think you've told me before that MongoDB
despite its name is not actually good I
mean up to what size of database does it
make sense
okay if we're storing a bunch of images
and I have you know five terabytes of
images yes make sense to stolen MongoDB
or does it make more sense to store the
images in the file system okay that's a
very good question
so there's okay actually there's
companies that do content delivery that
use MongoDB directly as a filesystem so
the main use case where you get major
advantages is if you want to
geographically distributed file system
yeah help you why does MongoDB help you
with that because it can store files so
it has a native stock file storage
called grid FS and grid of s it's
basically just another collection and it
cuts up the the files into pieces of
like sixteen megabytes and because
MongoDB itself like documents can be
distributed across or geographically
distributed massively the files will be
the same way trust me
I mean so we use that for a cloud object
store Shawn yeah I mean this is this is
one of the major use cases of MongoDB is
okay how does it relate to like the Ceph
distributed file system I do not know
Stef very well no one else will have to
tell you something understand about this
with many people writing right from
different points is how do you deal with
like if I make transactions and stuff
like that how do we make sure that you
are not trying to modify the same
document saved I'm Sonali TB is atonic
at the level of of document operations I
think so because if you were to use it
for something like you know the file
object store and so on then we need to
have something that says you know this
is now locked you can touch it and so
you have as long as you work on one
document everything is that week and I
mean not all the time but you can
specify whether or not you want to get
something that is probably
written or if you want something that is
for sure returned and distributed many
ways to work with the atomicity and the
right okay right acknowledgement just
kind of stuff but this thing that says
dollar isolated doesn't work on
charlotte plasters like that's perfect
exaction right if you work on one
document yeah if you trying to work on
multiple documents and charlotte then
you can't there's no miss it if you have
more than one document yes okay so okay
zoom out for a second here okay let me
go back to the thing here okay so so the
question that then you're answering is
you want both cases you want both a file
system and you want the the actual you
know payload data in in the MongoDB
database and you're saying that the
MongoDB database doesn't fall apart
if I put a petabyte of data in it it
will still work as that okay I mean
that's the whole design that it can work
to any scale okay okay this major claim
at leasts okay so then for us we need
this concept that eventually down at
that bottom level association that can
either be the actual image for example
or there can be a file that corresponds
to that image is that right yes correct
and that file could live yeah even in
the database so it can live in some
phone store although we may need a
representation of something which is
essentially a lazy okay right now for us
a file is you know the file symbolic
object represents the file it does not
represent the content of the file yes
and so to some purposes we may want
something and we have that for images of
a you know dynamic image so to speak
which the dynamic image can if you look
up dynamic image you can use dynamic
image with a file
make right now make sure you spell it
right yes okay okay oh you can for the
fantasy audio the same thing I think he
could do yes right so in a sense there
is a I mean so then for you in this
MongoDB thing if we're dealing with
images and files you could simply use
dynamic image itself as the final you
know that then it will just work
presumably well I I guess I mean I think
you can do image processing operations
on a dynamic image and some of them will
even do really interesting things out of
core you get what I'm saying yeah
innocence and so that would be seem like
a very useful thing to have here but we
may want a more general construct that
is more like a dynamic file that says
this thing represents the content of the
file such-and-such yes I think says okay
so let's keep going here so you've got
this MongoDB insert okay so the idea
that since that the key that it
generates you can see like what's you
know has information at the generation
time the machine ID and whatnot then
let's keep going I want to go Blair yeah
we can also obviously have lists of
associations it's more efficient to
insert lots of things and then the
queries so the query is yeah the most
simple thing is that find one of the
headphones it just finds one documents
just a random document I think it's like
the first one that it finds okay and
then you can obviously have there's a
whole query language so the query
language is like yeah you build it with
associations so for example you want to
find all the documents with age five and
you find one of them with with that
criteria and there's like what's
frustrating about this is data set does
that with select you know hash age
equals equals five yeah exactly
this is a translation between the two no
I understand but but in general we have
this conflict because in the case of the
implicit entity stuff which works with
entities store we have the fairly
natural you know age arrow fire
type thing we don't have that in dataset
do we don't think so
right so what we probably need is a
wrapper function that's like query right
what you do is you say if you type it in
you know you say data set some just just
a data set and then you know outside the
data set the the query write the query
to the data set is something that says I
don't know let's just say the function
you know I don't know rows matching or
something like that alright but not the
right word but let's say wrote rows rows
matching as a function rose you know
with capitals well okay so you say yeah
I mean just an imagined system function
rows matching and then in the the
argument there will be you know age
arrow five yes for example like like
that see what I'm saying yes that would
give us something which is the the
analog of what we're doing with entities
can you comment on that database folk
here the III think that is fine except
again the thing I really don't like is
largest take lodges the hectare is the
largest I mean in custom entity sorry
not just expenses but when you're doing
stamps to you can always say give me the
five largest cities and that's that's
not a really a select anymore it's not
local their role operation anymore it's
the other possibility which I think
tally had discussed at one point is
simply having data set remove that rows
matching and just have a Jarrow for do
this and then be able to say age arrow
take largest two four or something like
this I just I think that that's kind of
what sometimes it wrong to be able to do
technologists like that it's not let's
that's a separate discussion could we
also this particular thing about having
these you know a Gerald four and so on
be something supported in data
could we get let's see Sushma could you
arrange I mean Xavier and the other
people working on their aunt ally and I
guess Sebastian we need to have a
discussion about that because if we can
do that we can potentially merge what
you're talking about here with MongoDB
with what's being talked about with
entity stores etc right and in addition
it's very similar to what happens in
text search which is also nice okay so
let's keep going so this is a very rich
query language like you can do all kinds
of things greater than obviously large
corporations whatnot this is the third
syntax for this is that you can project
so you can make filter out remove
certain fields from what do you mean by
that
so basically you often want to you don't
care about certain fields and you can
make it come back much faster if you
don't return them so you can write down
that so you're asking for in that in the
case of you know data set you would
simply be in that second argument right
the first argument will be giving you
the row the second argument will be
determining in that racket which fails
right exciting is this the set so we
will be good to get the syntax to
actually agree with the syntax for data
set so yeah I guess the trickiness with
that is so for a high-level view I
totally agree like that that's important
but for a low-level interface you know
you can look at the documentation for
MongoDB for how to write projections and
there's a lot of complicated things with
operators and various things that they
support that it's just better to say
okay the low-level framework can you
support that here how can you support
was all those go weird things because
the way that they do this is that with
dollars they can do any type in yeah so
you'd say something like let's slice
this guy well Tobias syntax like
this will be the dates will be a
compound objects will be slice of I
don't know zero to two or something I
don't know it doesn't read this matter
you can make what you're doing there is
you're making a partial MongoDB syntax
you would be better off just saying but
this exactly how the Python with all the
the frameworks work like they all do
exactly this thing like when used I
understand but the obvious thing to do
there is simply have whatever the
MongoDB string is have something called
[ __ ] query which has inside it just
whatever random string you feel like
putting in there you see what I'm saying
okay I see what you're saying so you
saying that's so what I would you
through those you'd say date arrow right
in that case you would just say you know
date arrow [ __ ] query of dollar slice
blah blah blah blah blah get what I'm
saying
yeah so instead of doing that
Association like that you'd say this is
among a query object no no no no no no
yeah when you get to down to this thing
where you want to say instead of saying
date arrow five you're using this fancy
[ __ ] queries thing to select what
aspect of the date you want to get you
could just do it with this [ __ ] query
with a [ __ ] query wrapper which is much
like what we have you know we have the
search query wrapper that takes the
various kind of shorthand syntax is that
are traditional in search engines
I seen again I think it's called search
query look look it up between you look
that up no search query string that's
the one okay okay so see that that has
all those weird things right all the
weird short hands and see people expect
from a search engine or in there right
okay so this so this will be an
alternative way of actually should be
called [ __ ] [ __ ] query string morio
query string exactly
okay so this will be now tentative way
of doing this yep okay let's keep going
I'm still you know things functions is
named like [ __ ] collection find one
leaving me fairly cold but let's try and
get through the end and try to see what
else there is here okay [ __ ] cursor
okay okay so basically yeah so find one
yeah that just returns a single
documents but find is where the action
really is and this guy it's yet so cuz I
for some reason by the time we're
talking about binary coded decimal and
cursors it's just like okay well you
need some way of having an iterator that
you can iterate over the data center I
guess I mean if you're doing not doing
functional programming you need that
well I mean how would you I mean yeah
you have to have some way of I mean you
know lazy evaluation I guess in the
functional paradigm yeah to have why
would you need to explicitly iterate I
mean in other words if you're doing an
operation over the whole data set then
just do it
but if you want it coming take care of
the question of which thing comes and
when well the problem is that if the
data set is one petabyte of stuff yeah
okay then you better be using Leonids
chunking mechanism which is a nice
functional thing that doesn't require
you to explicitly you know iterate over
anything but i guess i want to ask a
specimen mono collection collection find
one of this like select and select first
or first case in cases like i why you
calling them like that is it is possible
to the AP so MongoDB has it has a an API
that all the different drivers have to
follow to be consistent with each other
so it's basically the design is that
they're consistent with Python and they
the same naming is used
so between C++ or Python or whatever
else driver you've got these are the
names that's you need to support yeah
but I mean it's not solving the problem
that we're solving you've told me that
most of the time nobody has nobody knows
or cares that this is [ __ ] underneath
well no I mean ok there's different
levels that you want to use us at so
there's some users like there one of you
they wants to have some way of
interacting with MongoDB directly and
Mathematica and they want you know they
know MongoDB in Python or something else
and they want the same interface and on
Stack Exchange there's some of the most
up voted comments are people asking I
can't interact with MongoDB in
Mathematica so there's like that sort of
level like people that want to actually
use MongoDB and they have the same
functions and having it all the other
languages then on top of that you know
there's people that don't care about
databases they just want to have
something very simple they want a data
set and they want to have a back-end for
the data set you know that's something
that that's built on top over something
like this
but this is not it shouldn't aim to be
everything this is like a low-level
framework and you can build on top of
this keep going it's super fast sits has
no overheads it just does what it does
okay let's keep going you can read from
the cursor so sure I mean if if there's
a if there's a lazy framework that is
what is that return value is that the
success object again
or is that some kind of cursor location
which think the return value of read
occurs this is a document oh yeah so it
is really being read know what's being
returned is that similar to your when
you didn't insert what was returned from
the insert the inserts it returns the
key that was used for the insert so if I
started it tells me okay this key was
used and it tells you how many were
inserted etc okay so those are things
that document ideas document representer
exactly yeah
it's just the and again like if you
don't specify this field yourself then
it automatically puts in an ID in it
that's unique
this is the key value store it must have
a unique ID every document I guess
that's one difference with dataset is
that it has to have a unique ID I mean
yeah we could I mean in principle we
could say what the memory location of
something in data set was and that would
be a choice but I mean it's the unique
ID relevant to anybody other than the
implementer here okay so what you're
saying is in principle and it's actually
a nice feature that could be even useful
for a dataset is that if you want to
drill down and just reference a
particular elements of the MongoDB
database you can just get that UUID and
do it that way exactly yes so yeah you
could see it as a UID that every row has
in the data set is that every row or
every element okay every element well in
this case every row I guess okay so in
the case of a data set our way of
addressing an element of a data set
is essentially a path apart pause so
this is nothing yes right so this is
saying that which is kind of interesting
it's saying imagine that there's also a
UUID for every sub expression exactly
yes
it's interesting
no it's interesting now that we have you
you IDs for cells in notebooks for
example there is the interesting global
question of whether there's the
possibility of having new u IDs for
every or conceptually having new u IDs
for every expression part I mean you
know it's awfully closest to having you
know we're again returning to you know
it's awfully close to having a pointer
but it is it's a it's a pointer that has
is guaranteed to be unique
Shawn exactly hmm that's actually kind
of an interesting idea but but okay all
right thing everything so you can then
read lists you can all see reads the
whole thing you can obviously make a
dataset out of it straight away
and then obviously once you finished
reading out documents in analogy with
database link it returns null if it's
finished somebody's asking by the way
isn't the Mongol curse a server side
like a t-sql cursor in other words I
think the concept is yes it is I mean
it's it's it's a the cursor is a thing
that represents yeah I mean it it's it's
also a suicide competing and you can
actually get a list of curses that are
running on the in MongoDB if you want a
server-side is that there is it is not
just that you are referring to it in
some way on the client it is that there
is actually a data structure on the
server that represents this I think is
because there if you have a server said
could generally I mean maybe he's not
the case for MongoDB because I don't
know very well but for other databases
like postcards and so on if you have a
server set course so the cursor can
fetch for example one min euro and give
you a chunk of them so that you don't
blow up your memory so basically the
server set of course is taking care of
doing the query and returning to you
some partial result wait yeah as soon as
you need them okay so in the database
integration system do we have a notion
of cursors or not they are not exposed
of course we are using them we are
managing them underneath yeah in a sense
what you do look at there's some query
that returns me that's too big for
memory
sorry if you could make a query that
returns a number of documents or
information of that right now we kind of
lazy resultset either using lazy list
but of course like if you are doing
normal over query yeah then you're gonna
get the million rows and it's gonna blow
up yeah but it will be good to have
those things correspond I mean so if
there is a lazy you know essentially
what we're saying in both in all these
cases is that we want a lazy data set
because that's the original thing we
want here is a data set backed by
MongoDB you're saying the data set could
also be backed by a cursor in MongoDB so
to speak the cursor represents the the
query so not really it's backed by the
there's a collection and query would be
like a lazy results sets that you can
get the results piece by piece
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute so but why isn't that just
another I mean why isn't that like data
set again why is it why is it the result
set I mean it's it's well you're saying
it is a queried a data set that has been
queried but yes the results are not
returned to the client side they are
lazily kept I see right so in other
words in a simple case it might be a
data set blah blah blah of select blah
blah blah now normally that would be
happen you know immediately but you
could imagine a version of that where it
was maintained lazily exactly that's
what you want for large it says um and
then the question is let's see somebody
from the live stream is asking what
would functional programming on the
client side have to do with iteration is
that in response to something that I was
saying earlier about functional
programming in this so anybody want to
comment on that
I'm not exactly sure what the question
means all right um would okay
they um okay okay you guys are convert
the cursor directly to a dataset if he
wants and then yeah I mean this is the
sort of syntax that you would like but
yeah you can use it like this you can
iterate through a set of things like
this so what the heck I mean why isn't
that just a map why isn't that just a
map of quotes underscore ID on to data
so how would you terminate it then
are you just saying it you should
overload map to take in well isn't this
[ __ ] map [ __ ] map again you know hash
sign quotes of quotes underscore ID
I mean hash hash sign of quotes of
quotes quotes inside your underscore ID
thing I'm replicating oh I see what
you're saying I see what I'm saying yeah
if I'm like IDE and then maybe something
are you exporting anything ampersand
after that okay and then map that onto
your [ __ ] collection I think you know I
think that the the problem is not really
like you don't really need to call it to
mumble you can probably just over build
map in some some Sam's the main problem
is that you can't really have generic
functions and expect them I know that I
realized that that's why I'm suggesting
calling it [ __ ] map because there are
only certain cars but what I'm saying is
that map is exactly the same operation
it's pure function that's not exactly
the same pure function database
integration case you haven't we haven't
function what that we we introduced
entity function
which is something that will you know
will complain if you try to do something
that that that is not supported by the
back end and which has slightly
different semantics because sometimes it
operates on transposed results no it's
it's not yet in in the documentation
right but so what we need then is
something analogous to that in this case
that is the functional way of doing this
is to have something that is called
something like you know database
function or something um that isn't a
very good name for it but database
function which is an impoverished
version of func of the function function
that can take in those things which are
actually executable on the database I
mean I don't know how it works with
[ __ ] but one concept that's really
important for SQL is that not all
functions are created equal and some
some of them do aggregations fooled it
has a full aggregation framework okay so
I mean I can show you a few examples of
this if you want so I mean a very basic
aggregation operators sample but you can
do okay you can modify documents delete
them okay there's actually our
aggregation example here but fine you
can aggregate things as well like copy
at the mean of you know some massive set
of documents that gets done on client
side these funky [ __ ] collection
functions are there update many delete
many etc how many of these order so
that's a good question we can see very
cookie collection all your collection
aggregates that segregation very much
delete your what you've written in that
cell you probably don't want to do that
that doesn't matter
nothing gets it we'll just refresh it
I'm just gonna make a separate copy of
this thing and alright fine fine
um yes aggregation is counts you can
count how many documents that are
according to a query
deletes many neat one finding what's the
difference between aggravate like why
isn't count type of a creation I guess
it is a special kind of aggregation and
what sure why but it's it's seen as
separate we treated that way do you have
I aggregated by what yes like like for
example packets don't they don't make
the set usage from the documentation
this is a bug that hasn't been easy
fixes yeah well anyway even the in in
the one that we're doing for Frank is in
SQL there's a difference between
basically you you get to a table and
then you I don't know count how many
rows were returned with you you can say
count by sex and you get the number of
males a number of females in one fell
swoop I see okay not to say yeah I don't
think so
alright okay let's zoom out and we need
to wrap this meeting up soon yes so
you've got a bunch of pretty wacky you
know [ __ ] pandering functions here that
are you know very much following
whatever the conventions for the [ __ ]
you know api's have have been yes that's
you know okay that's fine for serving
one particular I mean you know I what
we've done in this meeting is to talk
about a few design tweaks to that that
will bring it more in line with other
things I think the more general thing is
to take what you've done and actually
make it be a way of backing datasets so
right and I mean you're also not showing
yeah I mean some of these things like
insert some of this stuff is just deeply
procedural programming like and just
seems like completely the wrong thing
but does it for a little framework that
is that that follows closely what
MongoDB does like that is the right
thing and with these procedural things
you can build on top of us I understand
that but so what we need to do okay so
you know they're two objectives here one
is just the review of this
going in as an experimental you know
package where I think it looks you know
it looks good
it looks fine that all all seems
reasonable it will be nice to get these
things like the connection objects and
so on straightened out so that those can
be you know so that as we go forward
even though the operations will change
that those don't have to change because
that's something where you know somebody
may have stored something with those
connection objects in it and so on hmm
but I think well I think we we were fine
with those now let's talk about the sort
of the more general roadmap for how we
integrate this with data set okay again
and well what do you think is the I mean
in you know to my mind one of the big
issues with data set is something you
know you are setting up a data set and
you want it to be on disk okay yeah and
this is one way of having the data set
be on disk so it is data set of and then
it's basically I don't know what we want
to call it
external what the heck is this it's an
external connection of some kind yeah I
think there is one important inference
mismatch here which is that in general
as if you do an operational data set you
get another data set back yeah the
operations are a bit more eager like
when you transform you you do some
operation that's doing a select you
don't get out too lazy resolved which
with data set
you don't get lazy result yes no no we'd
long ago you don't get to these results
we visit you all right
what I'm saying is that you indeed as I
imagine you have like one petabyte
mumbling thing software and then
you want to say select I don't know
the first specifically the the thing
mumbling you can execute the thing and
get back a list of results but it's not
clear to you that what you do can still
be represented as ax m'allister results
is still lazy that is those individual
results might still be quite big is that
what you're saying as opposed to you
drill all the way down and in the end
you're just gonna get the answer three
out what I'm seeing is that you called
selective data set with whatever
operation you still get a data set out
now can you do that among link like is
the can you still represent it as data
set that contains just a connection to
among linked thing
why am I see maybe using one of these
cursors may be modified what's that yeah
so it could be a cursor but then the
cursor not doing further operations on
that I'm not sure I thought you were
trying to sell me on the fact that
cursors with these things that could be
procedurally kicked in all kinds of
different ways I mean there are result
sets so okay I guess you could do
operations on them well like imagine if
you selects all that's back by will get
a cursor that automatically does like
the end of the clauses of the true
slacks or or will you have to do it you
know sequential wait wait a second wait
a second wait a sec you get out a cursor
that represents that result set yeah
then you apply another select and
presumably that result set is further
projected in your phraseology
to something different to an to a yet
further results set which is the you
know which is the combination of those
two things but it might not be possible
to do that on the database side so you'd
have to do that locally so you'd have to
date at some point you might have to do
it locally yes eventually there'll be
some operations that you have to do
locally but I mean yeah I mean I think
that one of the cool things about what
we're designing with Larry does Ricardo
is that basically since everything is
still a table
it's like this nice composition of
operations where I mean if you even if
you're doing a bunch of complex
operation until you call aunt Val you
you still have to like some kind of lazy
representation of a table of data on
database side and so all the operation
montane take a table and return table I
understand I think that the okay there's
a there's a zeroth level issue here
which is let's say you were sent to
table all but you want to turn it into a
data set okay you weren't you weren't
sent something which was already a well
formatted MongoDB anything you were just
sent the raw data in some form that is
you know essentially a file system right
yes so the very zeroth operation is how
do you take and this is something you
know tally was talking about at some
point is taking a CSV file and being
able to say dataset of a big CSV file
yes right which we which we're not doing
right now we're simply saying you know
in other words the thing we might have
is to say data set of file of whatever
you want you write that down in your
notes here's a that's sort of a
top-level case of a file of whatever it
is right we're not supporting that right
now
something got CSV for example yes yeah
and you know that could be something
that operates out of core it could be
something yes exactly
so we're not even supporting that right
now but at least it's fairly clear what
the transport medium is for a CSV file
it's just a CSV file right the transport
medium for what should be unpacked as a
MongoDB database is less clear even with
a CSV like you take a data set that's
presentable as a CSV file you perform
certain operations of it you might not
be able to save it again as a CSV file
because you change the structure
absolutely that's correct yes that's
absolutely correct so so that's a good
case where look there's there's the
question of what the native thing that
it came in as was and then can you
preserve that and my claim is that most
of the time what will happen
it will originally be imported by you
from some crazy random unwashed format
okay mm-hmm
then you will turn it into something
which in our case we want to you know
let's say we use MongoDB for the thing
that you turn it into right at that
point you cycle around in MongoDB
representing everything that comes out
as some kind of MongoDB object right and
maybe subsequently you export it as file
systems or whatever else you want to
export it as so so the thing we have to
understand is how do we assemble given
that something is coming in in some
random way how do we assemble it into a
big MongoDB database and I don't think
we're doing that by doing a bunch of
inserts are we or are we well we're not
automating at all no it's after the user
to read it in some home with Lyon or who
knows what I want to use how does that
work I mean how do you put it out into
the MongoDB database how do you look if
I have the thing if I'm reading from a
CSV file and I want it to wind up in a
[ __ ] database so what do I do
well you're right sir I mean if it's too
big for memory which I guess is the case
you talking about right no even if it's
in memory if it's in memory are UCSB
then what awake how do I write you know
[ __ ] thing okay sure I see you import
the file then you do [ __ ] insert your
collection inserts and then you have the
collection which one is inserted into my
thoughts it depends on suggestion
possibility of taking is there a single
file that represents among go data's
like with an Access database there's an
there's just a file that can represent
the whole database right you can dump
the MongoDB database into one file yes
okay so would it not be useful to have
an export format then which has the
feature that you
it will make that MongoDB dumpfile from
whatever data structure we have from
whatever expression data structure we
have it will create a MongoDB dump file
that's a useful thing right that can
then be used to know that can then be
the thing that you use that is then now
is essentially a lossless thing that you
can then compute with inside the you
know virtual data set I see you should
make a note that you get my idea you
know in the Sun what it is so like it's
basically yeah so example that can be
transported if you wanted to current
transport that to a cloud you could do
that and you could unpack it again as a
MongoDB as an active MongoDB database
see what I'm saying to text cell the
first thing it offers you but by the way
there's one another thing we could do
given that we are like super fancy
symbolic programming language is not the
whole operation that you do data set
never actually get executed so if you
have an out of court data set you do
select you do map whatever you want
I see exactly we just annotate them you
see yeah maybe we have some kind of
things that the worst like take that can
can move the cursor of like 10 steps
something like that 10 10 items if you
don't want to get everything completely
memory at the same time III think we
have to talk about it with the leonid
then and tally as well yeah being
something where you are effectively
maintaining a symbolic query where
instead of saying select on the data set
like that since usually the queries are
you know trailing things where it's data
set of the of the query we could say
something like data set of symbolic
query yeah exactly it's like somebody
query or something yeah where and then
then the way we would resolve it well it
isn't the right syntax the right syntax
is data set open closed and then open
and then symbolic query closed okay that
is good about about the design
in this case is that basically entities
are by design always symbolic and not
only when you apply until value you have
something that execute the query there
is not a clear distinction like that
there isn't a way of representing a
symbolic query this is not the syntax I
meant get rid of the select there okay
yeah I see what you're saying so it's
like data sets and then you have like
this of symbolic query and then inside
the symbolic query is the Select yeah no
it just stays unev alyou ated okay fine
we're in this right and then and then
you do another symbolic query on that
and then at some moment you say data set
resolved or some such other thing well
as soon as you try and get something out
maybe like normal or who knows what
maybe maybe it's just normal of that yes
does it or data set as either data set
resolved or normal normal would then
just actually compute yeah knows might
be useful to have something that doesn't
that doesn't like normal so it doesn't
return a list of associations but just
gets to dataset in memory and still data
set but it's a memory yeah I understand
what you're saying right so you don't
actually want normal so that would be
something like you know data set it's
something like data set oh I don't know
it's query resolved I don't know what
quite put the name in it I need to go
yeah no I think this is a very good
discussion to have all right okay let's
continue that one more thing I'm sorry
for the machine learning stuff that's
being done I assume Megan who has been
quite silent so far has Megan have you
been using this stuff yes I have and do
you want to give any comments um so I've
run into a few issues with really big
data sets but other than that everything
works pretty well I've just been
basically fixing the file references in
there so I've been doing a lot of using
the find using the insert using the
update function
and yes okay I'm just an example of
something you've done with this sure so
basically um you want me to share yeah
if you can just for a minute and
Sebastian can you hang around for just a
couple of minutes and then I shall feel
good um Meghan can you go ahead and
share sure so this is an example of one
example of what I've been doing let me
go back up here basically I'll connect
to the database and then we have there's
there's sort of a deprecated way of
storing file references that we're
changing because it's not supported
really in [ __ ] anymore so basically
what that is is there's a it's like file
dot I did it's a nested structure
there's the file name is stored in that
kind of a structure and then what I'm
basically trying to do is make it so
that it's no longer nested so basically
it's just file goes to whatever okay
being nested so basically I've just done
like you know do a query where you you
pull out all of the things that meet the
criteria so sometimes you have to do
this in chunks because it's it's really
large it's like nine million documents
in this collection so you pull out all
the documents that you're you're looking
at and then you know usually I will just
I have a pull out the file names
themselves and then loop over a list of
them to basically update the file
unfortunately the current version of
[ __ ] doesn't have it can't do cell
self-referential finds or updates which
is going to change in the future but
that's our version can't do that or
MongoDB in general the longer my ODB in
general couldn't do that so now I it's
being changed in version 3.6 which is
going to be rolled out next month okay
hopefully so what you were doing here
was basically this was on some image
data you know on some image training set
you're basically
so yeah there's a deployment of MongoDB
that we've got and there's all of our
machine learning data is inside there
and it started actually a long time ago
from Wendie days and it's now she has to
she's fixing a lot of things in it so
she's doing a lot of surgery checking
that there's no duplicates of things and
all kinds of things so this is a [ __ ]
instance that we have that is
maintaining our training sets exactly
okay so so how many so for example how
many what would the levels here how many
databases how many collections do we
have there's one sort of main database
that's like all of the actual real data
that we want to pass just a clean what's
works like so compasses like a graphical
user interface for the collections and
whatnot
you can just write quickly see what it
looks like okay maybe the password is
nuts yeah I'm opening the read-only okay
that's fine okay so this is the machine
learning data is sort of the main
database that we have where real data
goes in that we actually want to store
we have basically four we have sort of
sandbox areas for each user so that they
can upload stuff there they can decide
with talk on the database name machine
learning data so we have a bunch of
collections in here so each of these is
a different data set and then as you can
see like we've got these are ten so
basically I just has like a unique ID
and image class a validation role and
then a reference to the file name which
is stored on a three-disc okay so yeah
this has a lot of like really nested
stuff in here bounding boxes and
superclass class and image information
right and then there's like MS cocoa
specific stuff that you know has
different captions and like an image ID
from Emma's cocoa chili
dog spelled wrong oh yes it only has one
L but that's the way that that's not our
on our end no I understand it's not on
our and it's just one of those lovely
things in the structure looks like and
then there's like four files that we
extract lots of metadata like the size
of the images and the color space and
all that sort of thing if we have a
funnel that we upload here and then the
sort of workflows that people upload to
the sandbox and then Meghan approves and
then sends it to the main database okay
she's been spending most of her time
like fixing up the main database and
she's moving on to like uploading lots
of things like audio data and cool right
yeah it's great
all right fine so I think I mean I
wouldn't mind seeing this MongoDB thing
one one more time before it actually
goes into eleven three I mean you put go
ahead and put it all in eleven three
let's look at it one more time with
whatever cleaning we've discussed in
here included in it and then let's loop
back and have a separate meeting and
talk about the full integration with
data set that makes sense yeah thank you
that sounds good okay okay great thanks
all